other news tonight a scary situation for
one las vegas man after the rv he was
driving caught fire on a local freeway
this morning our nate tannenbaum drove
by the aftermath here's what he found
out
54 year old marco rodriguez may be a
lucky man but he's also smart before
taking his wife and kids on any trip in
that rv he wanted to first do a test run
maybe not like have a suit when he says
he heard what sounded like a pop as he
was driving south of 95 515 in henderson
decided to pull over at the auto show
drive exit good idea because the rv was
soon engulfed
henderson fire crews were there
lickety-split got the flames out in a
hurry just doing some final mop up work
as i got there marco says he bought the
1994 rv a year ago as a fixer-upper
project
it only had sixty three thousand miles
on it nathan tannenbaum live local now
rodriguez luckily is okay he says he
didn't want to talk on camera he is
planning on getting another rv but says
this time it'll be a new one